so of course right when the Republicans
are on the brink of actually doing
something right when they are on the
brink of wielding their political power
to impeach the president to maybe try to
rest some power back from the Liberals
they're going to distract us with a
bunch of flying saucers of course of
course we need a distraction so now the
house
is going to hold urgent hearings
on UFOs they're here Capitol Hill braces
for the UFO Invasion with an epic house
Committee hearing that's right we got it
baby we're getting the UFOs over here
I have one question I have one question
about the UFOs forget I'm going to put
aside I know Matt Walsh and I have an
ongoing debate where I point out that
extraterrestrial aliens don't exist and
Matt says a bunch of nonsense I'm not
even having that debate right now I'm
just all I'm asking is this question
how come China doesn't have hearings on
UFOs
how come Russia doesn't have urgent
hearings
urgent meetings of the senior leadership
about all the extraterrestrials E.T
coming to planet Earth how come if you
look at a map of all the UFO sightings
around the world how come I'm not saying
all of them are in the west in the
United States and Europe and how come
the vast majority of them are
foreign
what's that about
is this really an urgent thing do you
really believe
do you really seriously believe
that
Little Green Men
are the most or even a remotely urgent
problem facing our nation or do you
think it is bread and circuses
distraction
perhaps sincere
fantasy but perhaps cynical distraction
nonsense which do you think is more
likely seems pretty clear to me but hey
hey former Pentagon officials Former
Intelligence Agency people they swear up
and down that we in the United States
were in possession of Technology from
outer space
the objective here I think and the
opportunity is for the American people
to come to better understand why it is
that so many in Congress actually take
seriously the idea that there are UFOs
UAP that are violating U.S airspace and
the associated rumor allegation that we
may have in our possession
off-world technology recovered from
someone else's Space Program I've been
told that we have recovered technology
that did not originate on this Earth
by officials in the Department of
Defense and by former intelligence
officials
notice it's always I've been told by
very credible Anonymous people I listen
One Time One seriously you're not going
to believe this my my mother's cousin's
best friend from work her boss
Z's nephew worked at a defense
contractor and he talked to the janitor
who once overheard some kind of
anonymous guys talking about how there
are definitely UFOs
yeah and you can take that to the bank
uh-huh
so that's why we need to have these
hearings we need to have these hearings
so that the American people can
understand why members of Congress
might believe in extraterrestrial aliens
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 we
are days away from the Durbin Accords
the greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa are
expected to announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a real reality it will be nice to have
some gold to depend on text Knowles
right now
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to 98.98 98 right now go
to ziprecruiter.com if you are hiring
you're probably dealing with economic
uncertainty by definition now more than
ever it is important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully
ZipRecruiter is a hiring partner that is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
zip recruiters smart technology
identifies the best matches for your job
and lets you invite candidates that you
really want to apply to your job before
other businesses can snag them I
absolutely love how straightforward
their pricing is you know what you pay
for before posting your job so you can
stick to your budget with no surprises
hire the best with the help of a partner
that is all about you with the
ZipRecruiter four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
I'm not speaking ill of members of
Congress I like a great many members of
Congress some of my dear friends are
members of Congress
there are members of Congress who
believe all sorts of things that are not
true
not rational there's a member of
Congress who once in a in a public
hearing
asked if putting too many people on the
island of Guam would cause the island to
capsize
okay the fact that a handful of kooky
congressmen think that E.T is out there
trying to make contact with us that
doesn't convince me
the fact that Anonymous deep Staters
Anonymous people whose job it is to
conduct psyops are anonymously telling
us that there are little green men out
there I just
I just don't believe it
think about how the quality of cameras
has improved in the last forget the last
50 years in the last five years in the
last two years the quality of the camera
on your iPhone could shoot in a super
duper ultra high definition feature film
and yet the quality of footage of UFOs
has remained exactly the same since
1945. there has been no improvement with
it's always for some reason when the
cameras no matter how advanced they are
encounter aliens or Bigfoot the footage
gets really grainy I don't know why that
is it's really strange
just don't believe it folks why would
the government be putting this out there
though I guess we have to address that
question well
few reasons
one it could be our technology and we're
trying to be cagey about it two it could
be the technology of an adversary I
don't really believe that I don't think
that China for instance has technology
much more advanced than ours not yet at
least that's an issue that we'll get to
in a second uh it could be that actually
we've depleted a lot of our our defense
infrastructure and as China is rising so
quickly it could be that we're trying to
Bluff I think it was Darren Beatty who
made this point he said that he thinks
that the Pentagon in the Deep state are
just trying to Bluff and convince China
that we're in possession of ET
technology
it's a little bit outlandish but it's
not as outlandish as Little Green Men
coming to Earth
the evidence for which is nil it's zero
it's just the media how do we know that
there are little green men because the
media tell you so and because Anonymous
people at the Pentagon and Shady figures
in the the intelligence agencies tell
you so the the people who lie all the
time whose job it is to lie are the ones
who have convinced you that this is
likely uh doesn't seem very likely to me
seems like a nice distraction huh what
who are we going to impeach what are we
going to do about immigration oh is that
what what about the failing economy oh
look a butterfly that's not a butterfly
that's a flying saucer boy what a great
clip that was now
ring that Bell make sure you subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time